countdown is on until the 2022 nfl draft
right here in las vegas it is april 28th
but right now preparations already
started and as we approach draft day
it's going to get harder and harder to
get around the strip corridor mary jane
belliesa is on the strip with what you
need to know in order to get around
whether you're working or attending the
event
[Music]
starting the night of wednesday april 27
through saturday april 30th las vegas
boulevard will be closed from flamingo
stretching to bellagio drive and from
the strip to koval lane whether you're
working or attending the draft you need
to start planning alternate
transportation now as it won't be easy
to find parking for jean francois
co-founder of popped delivering gourmet
popcorn to hotels on the strip will take
much longer during nfl draft weekend
with three to five deliveries a day he
says he'll have an earlier start so he
doesn't get stuck in traffic so it's
just gonna increase the traffic all over
you know the side streets that we
usually take to go from one hotel to
another
so
it's
just pretty inconvenient because then it
makes delivery longer and
so you know as a business owner it's
it's not ideal tony carnevale owns
carnivale gallery at the caesars palace
forum shops he's glad to know there will
be alternate routes well we're fortunate
being in the forum shops we have uh
employee parking areas so we're okay but
the tourists that are coming into town
that's going to be another story and
again i think the city will have that
planned out and give people options jd
decker with the nevada taxi authority
says one of those options is providing
enough taxis for visitors and easy
access to rides on the strip with the
road closures that changes
the traffic and the pickup and drop-off
pattern for transportation so that's one
of the major issues is that
we've had to relocate and and
consolidate the um transportation
options
so we've been working with the
convention authority to
set up a central location off of the
strip
for
taxis and uber and lyft and public
transportation options other
transportation options include rtc buses
and the monorail now there will be major
delays during the draft weekend so if
you're working on the strip or the draft
remember you need to leave early we'll
also have a full list of those parking
lane reductions and closures on our
website at eight newsnow dot com
reporting from the strip mary jane
ballissa live local now